y
[Música]
en haití las investigaciones
preliminares por el asesinato del
presidente yo en el mod se determinaron
que un escuadrón de al menos 28 miembros
la mayoría colombianos y dos
estadounidenses anne haitianos
efectuaron el magnicidio el pasado
miércoles 8 sospechosos siguen fugados y
tres murieron
bolivia acusó al expresidente argentino
mauricio macri de enviar armamento a ese
país en la crisis de 2019 que terminó
con la salida del entonces mandatario
evo morales y la muerte de más de 20
personas en protestas a favor y en
contra el mandatario argentino alberto
fernández pidió perdón en nombre del
pueblo
y en el último reportaje de nuestra
serie de frente al cob y un año después
nuestros periodistas se reencontraron
con luz una colombiana de 78 años que
vive en el norte de parís pese a su edad
y a la pandemia debe trabajar para
sobrevivir y sin permiso de residencia
mi nombre es ángela gómez iniciamos el
informativo en francés 24 vamos a
comenzar en el caribe según las
investigaciones preliminares por el
asesinato del presidente de haití yo en
el mo dice el miércoles en la madrugada
un escuadrón de al menos 28 mercenarios
compuesto en su mayoría por colombianos
y dos estadounidenses haitianos llevó a
cabo el magnicidio las autoridades
hicieron desfilar a algunos de los
sospechosos ante los medios de
comunicación y dijeron que 8 seguían
prófugos y que otros tres murieron
modise fue asesinado por hombres armados
en su casa de puerto príncipe- enviando
al país más pobre de américa a una mayor
agitación con divisiones políticas
hambre y violencia de pandillas
alineados para ser grabados por la
prensa estos son algunos de los hombres
que la policía haitiana acusa de
asesinar al presidente joven el mois
según las autoridades un escuadrón de 28
personas compuesto por 26 colombianos y
dos estadounidenses haitianos llevó a
cabo el asesinato tres de ellos han
muerto en un tiroteo y al menos ocho
siguen prófugos
nosotros capturamos 17 personas de ellos
15 son colombianos
los hemos identificado por medio de sus
pasaportes y tenemos dos ciudadanos
estadounidenses haitianos también
capturados
el ministro de defensa colombiano dijo
que seis de los presuntos asaltantes son
antiguos miembros del ejército
colombiano y que el gobierno está
cooperando con la investigación en el
exterior de la comisaría que alberga a
los sospechosos los lugareños gritaron
consignas de enfado y quemaron varios
coches que se creen que les pertenecían
a esa normal pagar a los extranjeros
para asesinar al presidente esto no
debería volver a ocurrir todos los
haitianos deberían rebelarse moix fue
asesinado en su domicilio privado
durante la madrugada del miércoles y
algunos han acusado a su equipo de
seguridad como personas de inacción la
fiscalía del estado dijo que dos altos
funcionarios de la policía responsables
de la seguridad del presidente serán
interrogados el asesinato ha provocado
una gran confusión a la hora de
determinar el líder legítimo de haití
con dos hombres que reclaman el poder
justo antes de su muerte moix nombró a
ariel henrik como su nuevo primer
ministro pero aún no había tomado
posesión por ello el primer ministro
interino claude joseph asumió el
liderazgo y declaró el estado de
emergencia durante dos semanas
josep se ha comprometido a celebrar
elecciones en septiembre
estaba previsto una medida respaldada
por washington y naciones unidas'
el gobierno de bolivia acusó al gobierno
del expresidente argentino mauricio
macri de enviar material bélico a ese
país durante la crisis que en 2019
terminó con la salida forzada del
entonces mandatario evo morales y la
posterior asunción de jeanine áñez al
poder el canciller boliviano mostró
pruebas del agradecimiento de las
fuerzas armadas bolivianas argentinas
por el envío de municiones y gases
lacrimógenos un hecho por el que el
ahora mandatario alberto fernández le
pidió disculpas en nombre del pueblo
informe de aurora bayern
es violaciones de derechos humanos
bolivia arremete contra el gobierno del
expresidente argentino mauricio macri el
canciller del país andino rogelio mayta
sacudió este jueves el tablero político
regional a revelar pruebas que salpican
al anterior gobierno argentino y lo
involucran en los hechos de violencia
que en 2019 terminaron con la salida de
evo morales- del poder pero resaltamos
que la argentina presidida por mauricio
macri le dio a las fuerzas militares que
reprimieron la protesta social el año en
noviembre de 2019
y munición
letal el 13 de noviembre de 2019 se lo
agradecieron
el 15 de noviembre de 2019
dos días después se producía la masacre
destacaba en las llamadas masacres de
sacaba en cochabamba y se encarta en la
paz murió más de una veintena de civiles
en enfrentamientos con el ejército
boliviano cuando ya nine años ya había
asumido como presidenta interina para
respaldar sus denuncias el canciller
boliviano presentó una carta firmada por
el entonces comandante de la fuerza
aérea boliviana jorge gonzalo terceros
dirigida al entonces embajador argentino
en la paz
en ella el militar le agradece al
diplomático el envío de material bélico
de agentes químicos como cartuchos y
gases lacrimógenas
el actual presidente argentino alberto
fernández afirmó sentía dolor y
vergüenza en una misiva que remitió a su
homólogo boliviano luis arce se constató
que desde nuestro país se remitió una
partida de material que no puede ser
interpretada sino como un refuerzo a la
capacidad de acción de las fuerzas
sediciosas contra la población boliviana
en esos días se trató de una
colaboración decidida por el gobierno
del entonces presidente mauricio macri
con la represión militar y policial que
sufrieron quienes defendían el orden
institucional en su país
el ministro boliviano también señaló a
ecuador de haber asistido al gobierno
interino de agnès jorge gonzalo terceros
se encuentra actualmente en prisión
preventiva acusado de sedición
vamos a bangladesh en el sur de asia al
menos 52 personas murieron y 20
resultaron heridas durante un incendio
en una fábrica que elaboraba bebidas de
mango con la marcas están los plásticos
las sustancias inflamables y los
productos químicos dificultaron la
extinción de las llamas sumado a esto el
fuerte calor del fuego causó grietas en
el edificio se desconocen por ahora las
causas del incendio y se teme que más
personas sigan atrapadas en el lugar
sudan del sur el país más joven del
mundo y uno de los más pobres celebra
hoy una década de independencia pero la
violencia sigue presente pese al acuerdo
de poder compartido firmado en 2018
contra la guerra civil tras décadas de
guerra de guerrillas este 9 de julio se
celebra el referendo que votó a favor de
la secesión pero desde entonces una
brutal guerra civil ha dejado casi
400.000 muertos y 4 millones de
desplazados 4 de cada 5 personas viven
en la pobreza absoluta
y en el último capítulo de nuestra serie
de frente al cobismo un año después
hoy nos reencontramos con luz osorio una
colombiana de 78 años que vive en el
barrio de sant de cni en el norte de
parís y a quien conocimos en la fila de
ayuda humanitaria pese a su edad de luz
debe trabajar activamente para vivir en
francia países donde no tiene permiso de
residencia la pandemia hizo tambalear su
frágil economía y comienza apenas a
salir a flote la historia es de erika
olavarría y yo le donne de lejos pero es
miércoles y en la casa de luz en sant
dennis el día de hacer arepas para la
colombiana de 78 años a quien conocimos
hace un año la cola de la ayuda
alimentaria el fin de las restricciones
no la ha sacado de su precariedad aunque
ha retomado las horas de limpieza que
realizaba en las distintas casas en
parís sigue dependiendo de las ventas de
las que llama panqueques colombianos
para mejorar sus ingresos cada fin de
mes su mayor preocupación es el pago del
alquiler
mejor si mejor más tranquilita porque
siquiera estoy al día con el lamento
le debo a mi hermana una plática pero yo
espero ahora que pasen estas vacaciones
pues le abonaría una porque ahora se van
las patronas
sin trabajo
y espero que la gente con maletas a ver
tras el reportaje en france 24 toda una
cadena de solidaridad virtual se creó en
torno a luz varias personas en su
mayoría colombianas en parís y en el
extranjero le aportaron con dinero que
le permitió pagar su deuda de alquiler
son ayudas excepcionales lo sabe que sin
papeles no tiene derecho a ningún aporte
económico del estado con la ayuda de la
humanitaria que la gente me dio cancele
lo que debía y ya pues estoy al día
gracias adiós
lo más importante en mi ayuda medical
que lo queme con eso no tengo que pagar
nada de medicamentos ni en nada
en francia la vida parece retomar su
curso pero en el caso de luz ella sigue
dependiendo de la mente
la pedía antes de la pandemia y la sigue
solicitando hoy y es que el coi no hizo
sino agravar su situación de precariedad
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom buenos días
[Música]